watching these lectures on iTunes these
days on their on their on their iPod so
it's just kind of so it's a big
responsibility for me to be to try to
get that right now now I don't know if
people are going to
be down Le hey okay hello everyone this
is the welcome this is the uh the 13th
time I've done this uh at at uh in
December giving a talk about uh what I
thought was the the coolest thing I
learned about trees during the year the
annual Christmas tree lecture um and um
and uh well it's usually not always the
thing I learned in that year because uh
because there's so many interesting
things you have to carry something over
from last year so what I'm talking about
today is actually is actually a followup
on one of the questions that that um uh
somebody asked I think it was L ramshaw
the lecture I gave a
year little more than a year ago at at
Halloween time uh when when I was
talking about something we called plgic
uh
Computing uh since then we changed the
the people in in Greece didn't like the
the name Plato logic and and we we
tossed around a bunch of Greek terms and
find out found out that actually an
English term would be better so we're
going so I'm calling that whole whole
topic broadw Computing now instead of
plat but anyway uh I mentioned at it in
response to one of the questions at the
end of that lecture I just made a brief
reference to to sideways heaps and
that's the topic of today's lecture
sideways heaps which I think is really
something that uh uh deserves to be
really well known um uh it's it but I
don't think there's any any textbooks
mentioning it at the moment um and uh
and so it can be a uh nice part of every
programmer's
toolkit um so what is before I tell you
a sideways Heap let me remind you what a
heap is uh uh in fact uh uh it it it's
kind of embarrassing because there there
are many many different definitions of
of heaps uh in in Computer Science and
Mathematics uh uh with different
meanings but the the kind that uh uh I'm
talking about Heap tonight I'm talking
about a data structure that's an
infinite binary tree or or a finite part
of of the infinite binary tree and it
looks like this um we got nodes numbered
1 2 3 4 5 and so on as far as you want
to go and it's a binary tree meaning
that every node has except the root has
two uh uh
children uh and uh so they go like this
and just
uh the easiest thing in the in the world
to imagine um U an infinite tree that
goes like
that goes on and on uh where we just
write the numbers um you know as long as
we long as we can um uh and
um
um uh of course we run out of paper
pretty soon and it's pretty crowded but
it goes on and on forever so this this
is a infinite binary tree that has U uh
uh no leaves because it never
ends
um but
um we it's wonderful to use this in lots
of algorithms because it's it it's what
we call an implicit data
structure where we where we have the
structure of a tree without actually
storing any explicit links anywhere we
don't have to ever say in any of the
nose of the tree uh this is the way to
get to your your left child and this is
the way to get to your right child uh or
this is a way to get to your
parent or to your uh or to your or to
your uh sibling uh because it's obvious
just from the address of the node itself
what it is so if you're at node
K uh your left child is
what 2K and your right child is 2K +
1 and your parent it might come this way
or might this might come this way but
your parent up there
is uh well
what do you
say k over2 rounded rounded to an
integer it's a floor of k over2 um I'm
going to I'm going to write it in the in
the C language notation way K right
shift one uh uh because we're going to
be talking about sideways heaps we're
we're going to do more complicated
shifting later and so instead of writing
you know it's also I could I could have
said K over two but this is this is uh
is going to be better our purpose and
what about your
brother uh your or sister I I mean I
don't want to be sexist here um
what what is
that K exor with one and and the C
notation for that is KX or1 but I'm not
going to use C notation for that guy I'm
going to use circle plus because I like
that better
uh uh this this other one gets too
confusing with exponents so so you're
you're so it's easy then to to to move
around in this in in this implicit data
structure uh saving you memory and also
uh if if we uh happen to uh have a a
heap of size 10 then you know we would
just take these nodes and we have to
make little tests at the end to see that
that we're not running off the end we
can increase End by one decrease End by
one if we want to uh but uh uh but
everything is compactly stored so it's
also very good from the standpoint of uh
of cached memory and other things that
make computers run faster okay so that's
the that's a heap
um
and what's a sideways Heap okay so
sideways Heap is something else that
really is so simple it's it's amazing
that it that uh uh it doesn't seem to
have caught on to to have a another name
so I made up this name sayway he last
year I don't know if it's going to
somebody might find a better name for it
but uh it's U uh it it's uh again an
infinite tree which which makes it a
really nice implicit data structure um
but uh it's quite different from the
ordinary heat because we as this name
might imply uh we're going to go at it
sideways so we start out with one and
then here's two up
here and then three
three and then here's
four um and um here's five down here and
the parent of five is
six um and then seven and eight tell me
when you get the
idea uh there's going to can anybody
guess what this no is going to be over
here 12 good good and and this guy is
going to be 10 here's going to be
14 13
15 um and up
here 16 okay now I'm trying I'm trying
to draw this a little bit carefully so
that if you project the numbers down uh
it it's going to be an increasing order
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 15 because
because you see the the um um soal
symmetric order of of the nodes in this
tree from left to right is is the
natural order of of the integer um okay
well now this tree uh so 17 is going to
be here and it's going to go up to 18
and 19 and then 20 is going to be up
here so now uh uh this is the sideways
Heap um and uh you notice that it has
plenty of
leaves it's got infinitely many leaves
right um uh all the odd numbers are the
leaves um and then what are the numbers
that are at the next level right above
the
leaves this is something that goes way
back and you know number theorists have
been talking about these things since
the medieval times but I mean there's
Latin terms for these uh uh for for
these U oddly even numbers right so
these are the these are are the odd
mules of
two and at the next level we've got the
odd mules of four and and the next level
are the things that are divisible by
eight but not by 16 and and so on okay
but the the the the thing is about this
this is a tree a binary tree but it
doesn't have a
root everybody has a parent nobody no
there not so so this this has a root and
no leaves this has leaves and no you
know infinitely many leaves and no route
now U guys who just came in there's some
there's some great seats up up in the
front row here and I can't lecture if
anybody's standing um and and in fact my
lecture improves exponentially with the
number of people sitting in the front
row uh
so yeah very
good
um so now let's
uh so let let's take a look at the at
the sideways Heap here W getting better
and better and
better
um how do we how do we navigate how do
we move around in thisis thing um let's
try to figure out a
rule
okay
prepare see where did you lose me a
sideways
heat I I see I all right so we want to
figure out how to move around in this in
this data structure U so we want to know
how to find the parent the the left
child the right child and so on uh now
can somebody let's see if we can think
of a of a
formula that would that would take us to
the um uh to the to the parent for
example
um
uh just consider the parent of a leaf at
at the
beginning um so the parent of a leaf has
to be somebody some odd multiple of
two so let's take let's take 2007 that's
a leaf so put 2007 in
binary
11111111
right uh
I don't know I mean I just happened to
know that one okay now what's the parent
of this of this of this
guy it's going to it's going to have to
be something that ends with a zero and a
and a one
here
okay it's it's it's got to be yeah it's
got to be an odd multiple of two because
all the parents of leaves are odd
multiples of two but which odd multiple
you know what are the other bits of this
thing you going to copy yeah copy them
all the same here um so this is actually
you know the parent is
2006 of of this year well I guess
everybody knew that U but you know
what's the you know this is the this is
the you
know the largest uh what do we call
these oddly even number what are
the the oddly even this is the this is
the largest oddly even number less than
2007 what's the L what's the smallest
oddly even number bigger than 2007 well
that would you I have to add one to this
this thing here uh I mean to these to
these bits all the way to the left so
that so that would end with a a one one0
uh so that would be up there at
20110 so 20110
what what's your
problem
make you
happy okay you know I I did that on
purpose just to see if
anybody um but
2010 he's sitting there with his little
um iPhone or something
figuring okay so
um uh what we're doing is actually we're
rounding to the near first uh odd
multiple of
two you know 20 2006 2010 it uh 2006 is
closer if I had if I had been at 2005 I
have my choice of 2006 2002 the closer
one would be 2006 so so so you round to
the nearest uh odd miple of the of the
next guy let's what's the parent of 2006
then uh well it's going to end end like
this and and uh the nearest is going to
actually be copying again so you think
oh this is just going to be too
trivial uh that's
2004 uh so what's the parent of 2004
it's going to have to go like
this now what do I
do set the bottom to one Zer that seems
to be right I just set the bottom two
bits to one zero and I'm and I'm in
business so um uh two thou that's the
year 2000
turn of the century and then you get
then the next one is going to
be
what this is 2008 yeah that's right we
we went
up 2008
yep I'm I'm anticipating
here what's it going to be at this
point I have to I it it has to end with
5 zeros and a
one um but now I don't want to go up any
any higher so it's going to be there so
actually 2,000 is is is is the next
ancestor and now we're going to start
speeding up
here this guy is
2016 hope to live that
long
what
next
oh well this one is George Orwell's
favorite year
1984 and um and then we go you know and
so on uh we're going to start creeping
into these ones here we're going to get
1920 and then we're going to get 1792
the French Revolution and then 1536 and
10,000 24 and then we're going to zoom
up uh 2004 we're going to go up by
powers of two afterward so so we've
moved up there in you know up in the
tree and now what we want is a Formula
that will take us from K to it to the
parent of
K all right now here's where um uh I
might want to take a a simpler thing
first
um
uh although um yeah I'm going to take a
simpler thing first let's try to figure
out the sibling of of of a node now
remember that remember our node for our
rule for for finding the the the the the
brother or sister um in in the Heap was
to do an exclusive or of one now what's
the rule here if we're if we're a leaf
um we're going to uh change 9 to 11 7 to
5 1: 3 what does that what is that
that's an exclusive or of of
two on the next last bit if it's up here
we're doing the exclusive or of four and
here an exclusive or of eight and so on
C that complement the next to the last
bit exactly that that that that
preserves everything and so what's the
last bit of a of the number K and here
we have something that I talked about
when I talked
about fro word Computing that's K and
minus k
if you if if you compute K and and
logical L with minus K you get you get
the lowest bit uh and so if you if if I
now shift that left one it's one it's
one more one one bit to the left of the
lowest bit and so I take K exclusive or
with this guy and this is equal to the
sibling of
K now now um do a similar thing to get
the parent of
k
um
um so I'm I'm I'm going to um first I'm
going to calculate J which is the which
is sorry forget it J is K and minus K
this is the the least bit of k k is is a
positive integer so it's always got a
it's got a least bit so so this is going
to be a one followed by as many zeros as
as as as the level we are in the
sideways Heap uh now I want to uh go to
the parent I want to round I want to
round that up and so what and so the
rule is well I'm I I'll I'll write it
down and then then then you can see the
point is not that that you can discover
the rule but that it's a simple rule K
minus J or with K left shift
one uh in in the simple case that that J
was equal to one now if you have a leaf
uh an odd number is the idea of an odd
number is when K and minus K is is is
one um uh and in that case U what we're
doing is we subtract one and then or in
U or or and one to the left that's
another way of saying this operation
that I just did on
2007 what J shifted one perhaps instead
of
k um I could have shifted
okay no uh uh it's not oring it in
because I have to zero it out too I mean
let's let's try let's try that it's it's
it's a good suggestion but let's try it
if I have like five or let's say six
okay so so then this is K uh and then J
is is is
this um you know minus K to get minus K
you you you complement everything to the
left of the
of the
um you know that's minus K right there
so so I Ed with minus K and everything
everything zero out except at the except
for for the rightmost two bits but now
if I shifted J left
one oh this here you mean this guy yeah
that that's that's right I thought you
meant I should shift uh J1 before I
before I do it here but that's but
you're right yeah I I I I I um I I have
to shift in this this number which would
be two if J is one or four if J is two
or whatever okay so that's right I have
to or that in but then but but I
subtract I first subtract and then I or
then I or and and that that that gets to
the parent so this is parent of
k um and The Sibling of K we got now the
the
um
uh the uh
children can also be found easily but
let's go on and and
um
uh
uh I guess what it is is I might as well
we say the children the children
okay um just just to prove that it's it
it's it's nice it's K minus J right
shift one and K plus uh J right shift
one and of course when J is one uh you
don't have any children so this this
formula gives you K back again uh you
know the leaves don't have any children
so so so that so this is if
IFK not
odd so so we can we can navigate then in
a sideways heat and get get around and
we have the other advantages uh that it
it it accommodates uh uh uh uh
if if we if we want to look at uh just a
small finite segment of this uh uh we
could get a sideways heap of of 10
elements and almost as good as as taking
a heap of 10 elements but not quite uh
if if I if I look at the at the first 10
elements of this thing I really sort of
want to include number 12 in here too uh
in order to have it in order to have a
tree structure because sometimes the uh
the parent will take you out of the
first
n you know of the first n elements but
it'll never take you uh past 2 N it'll
it'll always be less than 2N in fact so
so uh it's still compact uh if you have
a a sideways Heap with uh uh you know
with thousand elements U uh you're never
going to need anything 2,000 or more uh
any addresses 2,000 or more showing up
in this uh in this thing but there but
there is this little little glitch here
uh now there are so these properties um
uh with respect to data structures were
I believe First noticed by
um by a man named dove harell in his PhD
thesis
1980 um and when you see a reference to
a paper by d
harell uh
uh chances are the paper is by David
uh uh because he he wrote more papers
uh uh whose thesis was 1978 and had
nothing to do with sideways heaps
whatsoever so D harell there's two D
harls that that are that have been doing
great computer science at least and uh
uh David herel is my uh is my
grand a thesis student he's a he's a
student of my student Von Pratt and do
herel is is a grand student of Jeff
Alman um so anyway there there's all all
Stanford connections here you have to
see uh uh somehow but uh but um but I
don't think either Jeff or I uh realize
that sideway Heap was going to be a
really nice implicit data structure but
if Jeff is here he can tell me he can
tell me the opposite uh okay now let's
see the people who are standing in the
back I mentioned before that the lecture
gets exponentially better the more
people are sitting down and the closer
to the front you sit the better so
please come please come up here
and um now um one of
the but you say well okay so it's it's
cute but but uhu but what what good is
it and one of the nice
uhu one of the nice applications uh is
is actually
even more recent um uh to uh and uh some
people in Finland uh kaj Jan and
uh described a data structure that they
found was was very nice and compact they
call it a navigation pile you see that
yeah so so uh what they what we're doing
here is I'm showing you a um an example
of a navigation pile with 10 leaves and
in this case uh it's different from 10
nodes because uh but it's sort of uh
it's sort of similar it's as if I had 20
nodes instead of uh if I have n leaves
and two n n nodes
uh what they're what they're doing is
they're representing a priority que with
a uh uh sideways he the priority Q is a
data structure that's good at finding
the uh let say finding the largest
element and then you can delete the
largest insert a new element and and
update your your data structure and
always be always be able to to
quickly zoom in find find the largest
guy and uh uh and in fact Heap that that
was the first application of heaps uh
was to was to use them as a priority cue
and to and and to move things around so
that the largest guy was in the roof and
that uh uh and then U it you you you you
put numbers in you put data in in the
cells and then then you play a
tournament and if and the winner of a
tournament bumps out the you know moves
up and and and the guy up there moves
down anyway you get to to a heap
condition uh well uh navigation pile is
is different idea U you put the data all
in the leaves uh but then uh then up
here uh you have a point to the largest
people in your sub largest guy in your
sub tree so under node two he would
point to node one because the the
largest Leaf in his subtree is is 503
being bigger than
087 um uh six similarly points to 512
here four points to 512 also because the
largest of the Four Leaves underneath
node four is U is 512 the largest of the
eight leaves under underneath node 8 is
9008 so eight points down here uh 12
has four guys under it 9008
1702 275 897 12 points are the biggest
of these so this is the this is idea of
a navigation pile but the uh
uh it's very similar to what we've been
doing year for years and years when
we're doing uh some something called
replacement selection sort the various
things but the the the new the new idea
that made that made this work especially
well is that they realized that these
pointers
only have you only need a one bit
pointer for the guys at this level it's
either a pointer to the left or to the
right you only need a two bit pointer
for the guys at the next level up
because because four can point to only
you know four places so so so you can
encode that at two bits 0 0 01 1 011 and
similarly at the next level three bits
uh is all you need for the pointer so so
you can pack this this navigation pile
into very tightly into memory the leaves
are sitting here and and that's your
data it might be a whole word of data
but but you can keep all of the uh all
all of the pointers uh for n words of
data you only need two n Bits uh to to
store all the pointers in in the in the
navigation pile and instead of two n
words of the of uh uh so this is a
factor of 64 you're saving a lot of
memory and a lot of space in cash
um now now in order to extract these
pointers you have to you have to do
shifting around and masking in the
register uh you have to you have to do a
little calculation uh given that you you
know give given that you want to know
the the um uh the pointer from node 16
for example uh you have to say well
these it has four bits and those four
bits are packed somewhere um uh where
are they uh and then you have to do a
dozen or so uh computer operations to
unpack these but the way computers work
now uh that's things a computer does
fast a a computer can can go through a
dozen
instructions but but but as soon as it
tries to to to access memory it slows
down because memory speeds are getting
have have not followed M's law uh the
way register speeds have and so so you
you know you're often taking uh
uh order magn orders of magnitude longer
when you when you reference memory but
but if but but just taking packed arrays
of bits and shifting them around and and
and extracting out the pointers uh goes
fast now so that's the idea and of the
navigation pile and uh if if you want to
know where uh so so let's let's imagine
that I that I actually um uh uh was
storing this in memory and packing it
together um well I can show I can show
you here here uh just is
uh let's see can we I'll
um there's there's an exercise coming up
what I'm showing you here is draft of of
uh section 713 of art of computer
programming it's going to be published
next spring uh so here's the navigation
pile of illustration in the text and
then at the end of that section U
there's an exercise 153 which says uh uh
we could we could pack the pointers in a
binary string so the first pointer see
from two is a zero from six is zero from
10 is zero 14 is a one um and uh the
pointer from four is a two bit number
pointer from eight is a 3 bit number
pointed from 16 is a 4bit number um and
the question is what bit position from
the left is for the the pointer from
node
J um and the answer is uh
uh is that
um that the number of pointers in in not
the the number of bits in a pointer in J
is what we call row J this is the ruler
function of J um and I talked about it
in my in my other lecture but this is
the this is the number of
zeros
um the number of zeros
of zeros um after uh after the
rightmost the rightmost
one so an odd number row of J is zero
and odd an an oddly even number the row
of J is one and so on so this is the
number of bits in pointer from node J in
a sideways heat and in the navigation
pile it's the number of bits in The
Pointer um the number of zeros and then
um
uh there's a nice identity uh in order
to get up to that up up to J we we
calculate Row one plus
row2 plus uh and so on up to row J it
turns out that there's a very simple
formula for this this just happens to be
J minus new of J or new of J is the
number of one bits in in
J well for for example
um row of one is zero row of two is one
row of three is zero row of four is two
let's take Jal 4 uh 4 -
um is you know J Jal
4 if J equals 5 it has two it it would
be 5 minus 2 uh would be one you know
this plus 2 + 0 and J = 6 would be the
next case 0 1 0 2
1 which would be 6 -
2 the sum of this is four right so so
this is a nice identity uh uh that tells
you as long as you can as long as you
can easily calculate the number of one
bits in an integer you can easily
calculate where you've stored this U uh
the uh pointers for navigation pil
questions on
this so U this is the this function new
new J actually um uh for 50 years people
have called it the sideways addition of
of an integer you know you sort of take
a binary number and add sideways and add
add all the ones and um uh but U um more
recently people are calling it the
population count function um and their
other their other names but the but it
but uh a lot of computers have this
built in
now uh so it can be done easily
okay now um uh while I mention the row
function let me let me mention another
the uh the dual function which is the
Lambda function which is the number of
zeros sorry I can't write anymore
getting very old after the leftmost
one um so uh this is also uh equal to
the floor of the log base 2 of
J but so if I have a so so I have a
number 2007 and uh remember what that
was
so
um doing here
01111 um so then row is zero and Lambda
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 um the number of of digits let's call
it of
bits after the leftmost one it's not the
number of zeros I'm sorry it's the
number of bits
bits after the leftmost one so it's it
um
uh it's a uh an amazing thing that there
there's there's an identity that
connects the row and the and the Lambda
functions and this is something that uh
uh really surprised me when I discovered
when I when I ran across it uh like I
think it was a year ago and that is this
that if we take the
maximum of row of
I row of I +
1 through row of
J
equals Lambda of J and minus
I now
uh don't ask me why such a formula
should exist but it's but it happens to
you know it just happens that it works
out and so uh somebody give me an i
let's try an i and J and and and and try
to understand why this is true so so let
I don't know take I
equals five and and J
equals uh n let's say okay so um uh row
of I so so row of five is zero so let me
let me write it down row of five row of
six row of seven row of eight row of
nine so I want the max of
this so that's the max
of
0 1 0
3 zero
okay now what is what is J what is nine
and minus I so 9 this is J is N9 that's
101 minus
5 is minus 5 that's uh I complement
everything this is one zero a whole
bunch of ones here so I I and these
together and I get 1 0 0
1 no yeah 1 0 0 1 and then Zer
afterwards so I take Lambda of this and
Lambda of this is
three okay so it just works I mean or or
or at least you can you can pretty you
know you look at the you you look at the
sideways Heap and you see why it works
so so we'll look at the sideways Heap
and and so what we're doing is suppose
we take an interval in the sideways Heap
that means you take consecutive nodes
from I to J
and then you know so so I might start at
six or something but then it then it's
going to go down and go you know it's
going to go go for a while uh so what's
the the highest it
gets
uh what's the highest it gets between I
and J and well the the the thing is you
can compute it by this by this binary uh
thing you take J and you take minus I
logical and of those two numbers and
then you then you look at the Lambda
function the logarithm uh base 2 and
that's how high it can get and you can
prove it by induction but I I I don't
know how to prove it by by intuition it
just seems that you know I U I I I
started writing down cases and it's kept
simplifying simplifying simplifying till
finally there it was in you know in in
in this calculation so it's
just it's just very simple thing all
right now what I want to do in the rest
of this talk is describe to you a
beautiful
algorithm
by Baro sheber and Uzi
vishkin uh sheber and
vishkin and this algorithm they
published in 1988 and boy I was it it
took me two days to uh doing nothing
else to understand it but it's beautiful
it's gorgeous algorithm and and I want
and I'm just you know at that moment I
wrote down to say someday I wanted to
give a computer using on a Christmas
tree lecture explaining this algorithm
it's just it's just fantastic uh uh
fantastically nice method uh uh for
solving the the problem of least common
ancestor in a in in in a uh Forest uh so
now let so I've got to Define what what
that problem is um and uh uh first first
of all let's
um let's suppose we just have U nodes in
the sideways Heap um do harell noticed
in his thesis that it's that uh if you
happen to have any nodes in the sideways
Heap it's very very easy to calculate
their least common ancestor the near
nearest common ancestor let me I got
to I got to say right nearest common
ancestor um
actually more Bob Tarin uh we got to
follow his advice he wants to call this
the nearest common ancestor and he's
right it's the better in a better term
than the least common ancestor although
it's U it um it's somehow natural but
but you know if you if you take any
family tree and and and you know you
meet some relative at Christmas vacation
and and you try to figure out you know
uh in what way are you cousins uh so so
you go back to your nearest common
ancestor and and then uh depending on
how far away that person is that tells
you how many know what kind of a cousin
you are and how far removed U you are um
and uh so you take any two nodes in the
sideways Heap and
uh uh there and uh it's not it's not
that hard to figure out the nearest
their nearest common ancestors by doing
this magic of anding and and shifting
and masking and things like that uh to
go now um but uh uh in general this we
don't we aren we don't have a perfect uh
binary structure like this uh somebody
just gives us an arbitrary an an
arbitrary uh oriented forest and and an
oriented Forest is a is a situation
where you have um uh if something like
this I I will uh draw you a typical
oriented Forest here
um uh uh b c let's put D here underneath
a everybody uh has at most one root Arc
coming out of it every node has has has
a pointer to a
parent uh except the root
nodes and and uh we actually imagine
that the root nodes have a pointer to
the to to a null parent so so there's
there's a there's this special
um
magical U uh
Divinity that
has is the parent of all the roots uh
but but but all of the um all of the U
um the Mortal nodes uh have have at most
one parent and The Roots have the have
have the immortal parent okay so this is
um uh an example of of
a of a
um a forest an oriented Forest so so in
this case the uh everybody has a parent
except the except except the RO there's
no Loops in the in in the in the diagram
and that's the idea so uh now uh in this
particular example uh there's no family
that has that has three children in it
but but uh uh the sheber vishin
algorithm Works in general no matter how
you can have families that are
arbitrarily large I just this particular
example um uh doesn't doesn't doesn't
make use of that but
uh uh this problem of finding the
nearest common ancestor of two nodes uh
in a structure occurs fairly often in in
practice where we where we have where we
have data that's represented um uh with
with a uh uh a cyclic structure like
this uh and and we like to find the
closest uh common way that that they
point to
every two nodes have a a a nearest
common ancestor because if they're in
different trees U it's the it's this
special note at the at at way at the top
uh is their nearest common ancestor so
the um uh the idea is uh is this
um
um if
if if youu goes to
V then then uh uh V is parent of
you uh if you goes in zero or more steps
to
V uh this is V is an ancestor of of of
you okay so uh the ancestors of uh what
are the ancestors of G in this
diagram D A and G G itself everybody is
considered an ancestor of their s
because this star notation means zero or
more times so so it turns out that U
that we that it's better to have this
definition where somebody is its own
ancestor because otherwise what would be
the nearest common ancestor of DNH you
know it has to be an ancestor of both D
and both D and H and so and so it has to
be d d would have to be the nearest
common ancestor of DNH and so okay so U
uh the idea is um uh the nearest common
ANC
sister let's just say the NCA of u and v
equals W which means that
W is an
ancestor um well well okay W is an
ancestor and it's and and every other
common so w is a common ancestor both of
them and every other common ancestor is
also an ancestor of w so so I mean
formally it says that if you if Z is an
ancestor of U and Z is an ancestor of V
then
W or if and only if if uh Z is an
ancestor of w this is the the definition
of a nearest common ancestor in logic
but but the uh but the the intuition is
clear now
um uh the I I want to describe to you
the the algorithm of she and vishin to
find the nearest common ancestor in a
such a data structure U and you might
say well why am I so fascinated by this
algorithm and the reason is that it it
gives you the answer in in a constant
number of steps no matter how big you're
no matter how big your data structure is
uh uh uh it it it just does it just does
a a few calculation Zip Zip Zip and it
says here was your nearest common
ancestor and and it does this by looking
at the uh uh you know the integers that
are representing
unv and some pre-processing has gone on
so so shishin algorithm is not a d it's
not it's not an algorithm for for the
dynamic nearest an ancestor problem it's
it says you got a fixed database and and
you're going to be answering a lot of
questions about common ancestors in this
database but but what but uh uh but but
when when you have a setup like that and
so you you know that a lot of people are
are going to be asking questions about
this same the same structure then you
can you you can make up a couple of
magic tables and and and and and and
shra bishin algor tells you how to
calculate uh the nearest common ancestor
just by a small number of of computer
instructions now uh and it's it's I I
think it's quite beautiful but amazingly
it's gotten bad press in the literature
uh as I said it came out in 198 and I
thought that as I kept as I would keep
on reading I would find people saying oh
yeah this is the you know here's this is
a great a great thing but instead I find
people recommending other other
algorithms that uh and saying you know
well you know here's here's my
Improvement on the she bishin algorithm
and when I look at these improvements um
I I fail to see why they're an
improvement because it takes you know it
takes it runs slower on the computer and
it takes me a lot longer to write the
program the only reason these other
improvements are improvements as far as
I can see is that uh that the proof is
simpler U now uh sure it's easier to
prove that some algorithm are correct
but the but the computer doesn't slow
down when it gets to to some stru
instructions it doesn't understand uh
you know this is uh so I I don't like
this philosophy that some people seem to
have that nobody's ever allowed to write
a subtle computer program that you you
know that if if if if uh if if um a
freshman can't understand the program we
have to throw it out because we won't be
able to maintain it I you know I this is
this this will lock computer science
back at a certain level that'll never be
able to advance between so when somebody
discovers a brilliant new algorithm that
runs fast so what if it takes a few
pages to prove that it's correct you
know the computer is still going to is
still going to go Zip Zip Zip and much
faster uh and the code is shorter and
and nicer so so I I think uh uh uh
sheber and vishin deserve to have their
algorithm better known I have to admit
though that that it took me two days to
understand their paper and and and it
might take you three days to understand
my write up of their method but but it
is correct and uh and uh uh and I I'll
just be able to give you the basic ideas
of it and then you can then you can look
at the uh at the text when uh later on
to see to to
see I I learned long ago it's not a good
idea to do formal proofs in middle of an
a you know in the middle of a lecture um
but at least I want to give the I I want
to give the basic ideas how they do this
magic so uh so listen up uh uh what they
have to do is is pre-process every given
uh structure oh wait before I do that
let me let me give you more motivation
why do why do we care about nearest
common
ancestor yeah so there's another there's
another problem that that is uh
equivalent to the nearest common
ancestry problem but it but it's it's
amazing that it's equivalent it's called
the range minimum query
problem um now the range minimum query
problem uh is U uh is the and I can um
give you an example of the range minimum
query problem uh we have an array of
numbers and I'll use pi as an example 31
41 59 see where did I did I work it out
here yeah 3141
59265 3589 I think anyway so so we have
an array of of of of data um and uh
these are in locations 1 2 3 up to
n okay
and and uh uh the range minimum query
problem
says give me I and J tell me the the
place where the smallest item is between
positions I and J
inclusive so if I is five and J is nine
uh then uh the
smallest the range minimum query would
say six because in in position six is
where the smallest guy is between those
between these these positions so so the
range minimum so K of i
j is is is is such that um a sub K
J equals the
Min of a
ofi through AF
ofj that's the the range minimum query
problem and in case of ties we take the
leftmost uh uh the leftmost position
where where it is now so uh the range
minimum query problem turns out to be
equivalent to the nearest common
ancestor problem and there's a there's a
beautiful construction that will
demonstrate this um and I show you how
it works uh you take these numbers and
you and you insert them into
a you aren't all going to understand
this but I got to show it to uh for
those of you who uh who do
understand let me sort them uh first
by uh with the bottom component first
and and so that'll be one two 1 14 uh 26
uh 31 39 and so on so so but then then I
enter them into a binary tree according
to the binary search tree method um
uh ordering with the top guy first so so
I I'll illustrate it so the smallest the
smallest pair here if I take if I give
presence to the bottom guy is one two
the next smallest is 14 I'm going to put
it into a binary three but I use the
upper guy now as the tiebreaker so is so
so in this case four is greater than two
next comes uh 2
six um and so six is bigger than four so
2 six is going to go here then comes 31
I so I'm I'm crossing them out the the
the smallest guy uh uh left based on the
bottom element so 31 is next but when I
put 31 in here I I I'm going to put the
one here to left because when I'm
putting into the tree I'm using the
upper guy um to to do the the Sorting so
um uh nine is is here
here uh
43 comes in here so four uh is tied with
this four but three is bigger so I'm
going to go this way I'm going to put
the 43
here and
um
uh f
five we'll come in here 5
8 will come in
here
um open in five get 510 will come in
here uh
67 so the seven is is is coming in this
way uh
8 3141 five I forgot the nine oh well
that's it's still
random uh 811 is going to is going to
wind up here in 129 okay so uh so anyway
I get a binary tree here a binary search
tree well it turns out that if you want
to find the range minimum query of two
guys it's just the least common ancestor
in this tree the nearest common ancestor
in this tree uh for example like you
know between 5 and nine we had uh
526 5 3
well that's this
52693 it's these guys here and their
nearest common ancestors the one that
happens to be highest in history so so
it so so this uh converts the the U
range minimum query problem into a into
a forest uh a binary tree in fact uh and
if if I can solve the nearest common
ancestor problem in the binary tree then
I've got the range menum quy problems uh
uh nailed and uh this this beautiful
construction was due to Hal gabal and
John Bentley and Bob Taron I believe um
and
conversely if I have a good algorithm to
solve the range minimum query problem uh
I also have a good algorithm to solve
the nearest common ancestor problem but
I don't know any algorithm for the range
minimum query problem that competes with
shebr vishkin so shebr vishkin is the
winner as far as I'm concerned for both
of these guy um when when the database
is fixed oh when the database is fixed
okay now let's so so now I I hope I
motivated this enough to why why
somebody would care about shiver and
vishin algorithm and um we now have to
explain how they do it and what they do
is they map
this they they map this given uh Forest
into a sideways Heat
uh in a very clever
way um so first of
all uh we we we give a number to every
node of uh using using
pre-order of the forest now pre-order is
is like the order of succession to the
throne so you imagine that the that
these are U you know kings and queens
Lords or something like this and the and
the first and uh you know the children
of uh of Queen Elizabeth or something
and so number one uh this this guy would
would be first but uh if if if U if he
dies this guy is
second um I think it's still a guys in
England I'm not sure but maybe not but
uh anyway this person uh and and uh and
anybody knows the Alec Guinness movie
where he kills off the the top 13 people
and then uh um then get thrown into
prison okay so U uh uh so this is this
is pre-order U the order sucession to
the throne will get four 5 6 7 8 9 10 so
in this ordering uh uh the children of a
family the all the descendants um are
are consecutive all the descendants of
of one are the nodes between 1 and
8 um 2 3 4 and all the descendants of
four are five six seven and so on it's a
nice it's a nice ordering so so
everything has an order now and we and
what we do is
um uh then uh so so I have my nodes a b
c d e f g h i j and I ass associate so
call this this node V and Pi of V will
be the order of uh the pre-order
uh index of V so a is 1 C is 2 f is 3 D
is
4 um G is five J is 6 h is 7 B is 8 e is
9 10 so these are this is pi of
v and
um
uh next thing I F I I have um something
called data of
V which is the which is really the
tricky part um and
um and I and I say it's
the um beta of V is the nearest common
ancestor
of all of
the of the following set Pi of U where U
is a CH is a child a a
descendant of
V not ancestor but descendant so um for
example to figure out beta of um of
D um this is going to be the nearest
common ancestor of all of the
descendants of D can you see them here
um this is then Pi of d uh Pi of G Pi of
J and Pi of H
all right so that's four five six and
seven it's always going to be it's
always going to be a
consecutive uh thing here because all of
The Descendants are consecutive in in
pre-order okay so what's the nearest
common ancestor of those four nodes in
the sideways Heap in the side in the
sideways
he uh so
if
the sideways Heap there's only one
sideways Heap it's this it's but but but
I'm glad you asked because you are not
the only person wondering about that in
fact I'm now wondering which sideways
Heap because I lost my picture of
um but here it is this is the sideways
Heap and so the nearest common ancestor
of four five six and 7 is
four right the nearest you know
okay so um if we if we ask ourselves
then uh if if if we have some node um uh
in
U and it's pre-ordered number is uh let
me take a random a random number like 20
suppose suppose suppose Pi of V is 20 so
so so I have some you know the 20th node
in in my given the 20th note in my in my
given for us um and now um how can I
figure out beta V well this is going to
be the nearest common ancestor of
21 up
to um something the last The Last
Descendant of of the of of uh uh
depending on how many kids or how many
descendants uh know 20 has and so if if
it doesn't have any 20 any descendants
at all uh you know so so so so the
nearest common ancestor of um of 20 all
by itself is just 20 if I have 20 and
21 uh well we we like I didn't put that
on the chart here but you have to
imagine that's 20 21 that's still going
to be 20 if it's 20 21
22 even 23 it's going to be 20 but if I
get up to
the nearest common ancestor of of is
going to be 24 because it's a multiple
of eight so so so this going to be you
know you know I'll I'll find the one
that has the largest Row in here the
largest value of the ruler function and
that's this what we figured out before
when when we had this magical relation
between the the ruler function in an
interval and the and the Lambda function
U so in other words the NCA of
if you remember of uh of
J uh through k um is is actually going
to be equal to Lambda of
k n minus J according to the formula I'm
sorry uh two to this
power no I'm sorry no that's not it
that's not it it's going to be uh the
ancestor of
of J at this level so so there's a
formula I have to write down but it but
it depends on it depends on this
quantity which I can calculate just in a
few a few machine instructions so anyway
the the uh the gist of this is uh then
since we're running out of time I got to
like it's going to turn out that that
beta of V beta of beta of V is always
going to be equal to Beta of V it's
always going to be a fixed point and so
on so so so but so I I can work it out
what beta of V is in this in this chart
and uh and it's not hard uh a has
descendants 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and so the the
the largest guy is going to be four
there for B it's 8 n and 10 that's going
to be eight for C it's two and three
which is two for D it's four 5 6 and 7
is four e is 9 and 10 it's going to be
10 I I just choose among all The
Descendants the one that that has the
that's divisible by by the most twos of
three all the leaves are going to go
into
themselves because they have no
descendants except themselves G has five
and six is going to be six and I is
going to be 10 so so anyway that's what
beta V
is and
um uh okay then there's an alpha of
v um which is um
uh given by a formula Alpha of V equals
the sum
of the sum of 2 to the row of beta of V
of w for all V that go through that that
are ancestors of w so anyway they
there's there's there are these magical
numbers that we can calculate and it
turns out that this is uh going to be
then turns out this four this is 2 + 4
those of you uh watching it on
television will be able to check me on
this but this is four this is going to
be 8 + 2
um f is um it's uh 1 + 2 + 4 it um it's
the you look at all the ancestors and
you add together two to that to the
those powers are two and you get a
binary number anyway these are all
numbers this is going to be a number
between one and
N uh and beta V is going to be between
one and n and alpha alpha V can is
always going to be less than 2 N so
these are numbers that we can calculate
and um uh I uh I will just write down
the the the the shra vishin algorithm so
that you can see uh
uh how fast it is and then and and uh so
we start out and um we calculate so so
anyway here's the shra VIS algorithm um
SV algorithm for the nearest
common or nearest common ancestor of X
and
Y uh the first step is calculate
H um is equal
to Lambda of beta
y ampan minus beta X sorry beta y %
minus beta X if beta X is less than or
equal beta y or the other way around
beta X and minus beta y if beta Y is is
is greater than or
equal e either either one gives the same
answer if they're equal the next step is
we
calculate um
K and that is alpha x anded with alpha y
anded with minus one left shifted
H and then we recalculate H and we
change it to Lambda of K ampan minus
K
three I set J to
um beta X right shift H or
one and left shift
H
and next step I set I calculate X
hat is equal
to
um beta X if
J equals I'm sorry X is X is equal to X
if
beta x =
j otherwise it's equal to to I didn't
tell you what to is
um of beta x
-1 yeah there's another table that's
called to where L
equals
um Lambda of alpha
x ersan one H you get it so okay here we
are all right so and N Y Bar is the same
thing uh with X and Y what what's okay
so now tow is um uh is uh uh this little
table here
uh okay I I'll explain it I'll explain
time a minute first I want to show you
why the algorithm is fast and and and
finally the last step is
um uh if then Z this is the nearest
common an this is our answer and it's
equal to xar if Pi xar is less than or
equal Pi y y hat sorry and Y hat if um
pi x hat is greater than or equal Pi y
hat okay well this is the this is the
whole algorithm and you see why I mean
that it that that that is okay it's a
finite number steps um it it it goes Zip
Zip Zip but it's about but if we count
how many operations there are um this is
one
two um let's see this is this is one
two Lambda cost something so that's
that's that's three steps here um uh
there's a test here there's a test here
and there's a test here so I have to
make three tests and then but then
calculations outside of the test uh uh
go this way I can do these things in
parallel uh modern computer here I've
got one op one two
three
four um let's call this four operations
I imagine that I fet fetched beta X and
alpha x already into register U or call
those two other operations if you want U
here's one two and Lambda is three
operations here's one
two three
operations uh
here it turns out I have to make no
operations or or eight operations if I
if I have do the second case and there's
maybe eight operations calculating why
hat and then here it's is just this test
again so so in total I'm making about 20
operations three tests and uh and I have
to fetch uh tow uh uh Lambda
uh I guess I counted Lambda already as a
as a fetching um uh but it goes It goes
Zip Zip Zip anyway much much fewer
operations than than these other
competing algorithms for the for the for
the thing um now um the intuition as to
why it works is that that that you map
the the the given Forest into the
sideways Heap and and you and you put uh
uh uh like in this part of the Heap J
and g go into the Heap I'm showing the
the beta value uh uh so so so whatever
whatever a node's beta value is you you
put it there in the Heap and and then U
everything that this this turns out to
be a useful operation also in in other
algorithms um uh based on the sideways
heat because what it does is it takes it
it it it it takes the an arbitrary um
forest and Maps it in into this nice
binary structure in such a way that if
if if several guys go into the same
place uh they correspond to a path in
the original Force so you divide your
original Forest up into little paths and
those little paths fit into the sideways
Heap and then to find the nearest common
ancestor it turns out to
be an easy in quotes calculation on the
sideways Heap um U because U it it it
can be done by
arithmetic okay so um it's not one of
those algorithms that I can prove easily
quickly but but when you when you look
at the code it's only a few it you know
it it's only a dozen lines of code in
your in in your program and the computer
goes very fast through it so this is a
uh I don't know I hate to say this maybe
you know do you mind if we have
algorithms of the future like this that
are based on uh that are based on on on
mathematics that takes takes improving
um I as I say the uh the computer uh
doesn't uh doesn't feel bad about it uh
the computer computer doesn't know if he
he's he's executing a stupid program or
a subtle program the computer just goes
uh just just goes and follows order so
so um that's uh uh a very brief and and
uh not too clear introduction but
I I hope at least those of you who who
ever need to calculate nearest common
ancestors will know that uh sheber
vishan algorithm is something to look at
if you're going if you're going to do
it hey thanks for uh your patience
getting through this I'm ready to take
questions reprocessing time yeah it's
linear that's a very that's exactly the
right question yeah that's that's
exercise 147 I mean yeah
does
the thees same time for both the range
minimum query and the and the nearest
count ancestor is is goes linear time
although although my definition was was
exponential time of the uh the actual
there's actually a way to to calculate
these magic tables the pi the alpha the
the too and the Lambda table which you
might as well keep in there um uh um all
uh all in in order and time where CL is
small thanks for yeah if you if you had
to if you were updating the treat could
you in constant time re update your
prepress you have to do your prepress
that's too bad yeah no no in that
case you get to log in there there are
other methods of very very complicated
which I would hate to program that that
you know that that do these in that that
do these fast but the so the shra bishin
algorithm is good for the static case
not the dynamic case U and U but it uh
but uh I like it both because uh it's uh
it's fast it it's you know and because
it's got this it's based on theory that
that excites me I mean I I I I think uh
uh it it just hangs together in a very
elegant fashion even though uh it looks
like you can simplify the reason I spent
I spent spent two days on it cuz it
looked like you you should be able to
simplify it U but then I showed that
that certain cases can it um certain
cases uh uh that that occur rarely uh
where you can sort of have entangling
things as you're as during this
embedding um you actually need the
complexities I mean the algorithm um you
know takes takes 25 steps or something I
I don't know how to do it in 24 um I
think each of those steps uh arises
because because unusual cases U uh
required okay so as I said a lot of
people came in after I've got uh I I got
some freebies on the table here for for
for Christmas presents for anyone who's
who's um who happens to get there first
and is interested and and so uh Merry
Christmas to all
yeah